so dude thanks again for coming out we
had a great day and going out and trying
to get your windows tinted on your Tesla
didn't work out too well they said my
Tesla back good months dude that's crazy
something happened yeah but you don't
need a car you just live on the beach
you just like roll around the beach
surfs Kim play video games how do I
leave my room it's kind of unless you
just need to go out and eat you know get
out you can just yeah sometimes they get
up screw it out you know yeah you pretty
much bottom all Tesla's already can just
use their car whatever you want
dude my dad and McLaren next snow I'm
just gonna buy your dad a McLaren what
is your dad drive you still drive that
like old stickered up hoopty car
actually in a few cars but we crash them
because you crashed them yeah there's a
video coming soon
well you've had your Tesla for like
three months and you've already wrecked
it what like three times you sideswiped
it you've grabbed the rims it's like you
just bought a car and then you decided
to learn how to drive yeah I never I had
a few cars going up but I actually had
like a real real car yeah I think I had
a 300 is e you did yeah holy [ __ ]
I was like in fast car yeah I always had
like it was automatic something really
like driving it
have you always like been really into
cars yeah a little bit what's that
little green car that you had that you
posted a couple pictures up like that
little like weird-looking green car it's
blue is it blue it's like it's a 1963
Volkswagen Karmann Ghia okay where'd you
get that thing for speed my dad bought
it oh did he yeah it's pretty fun it's
not fast but yeah it's fun dude so for
the people out there a lot of people
don't know I dunno but I just want to
clarify it
what does t foo actually stand for